April 21st marks the fifth anniversary
of record store day a nationwide project
promotes struggling brick-and-mortar
music shops across the country
independent stores offer exclusive
one-of-a-kind recordings as a way to
bring customers in their door according
to matt Moffitt corner of Washington
DC's smash records it's been a great
success it is the busiest day of the
year and we bring the most money and our
register on record store day which is
very helpful smash isn't just selling
new CDs like the businessmen in a tough
economy they've diversified them to use
albums hard to find vinyl t-shirts
posters and vintage clothing stores that
only sell music are few and far between
and and then on top of that stores that
only sell just new music I don't know I
can I could even think what's necessary
for record store in survival has put
them directly in the path of a threat
that far outstrips of music hungry teen
with a bittorrent account we're talking
about City Hall the powers that be in
the nation's capital have decided that
record stores in DC must now acquire a
different business license one that is
particularly burdensome and expensive
basically they want us to get a pawnshop
license all these stores so and in order
to get that there's just a million hoops
that everyone has to jump through the
regulations which I have here for
secondhand dealer Class A and Class B
licenses are particularly onerous the
toughest challenge for us would be that
every item that someone walks in to sell
we have to catalog we would have to send
like a sheet to Detective to say this is
what we bought this is how much we
bought it for then we would have to hold
it the items for I think two weeks the
investigators detectives can come in at
any time and they should have a current
list we should be able to tell them how
when why we're we got of every item then
and this is kind of the nuttiest part
for me whoever buys set items we also
have to take down their information so
I'm supposed to do that for every
item that we sell and that's not the end
of it under the second hand store
license owners must get fingerprinted
pay twice as much as a general business
license or face a fine of up to two
thousand dollars a day for
non-compliance and make no mistake when
DC is trying to stamp out business they
mean business Wednesday April fourth a
number of businesses in Adams Morgan and
also on U Street were visited by MPD the
Metropolitan Police Department along
with inspector from the department of
consumer of regulatory affairs or DCRA
they came in in a very aggressive way
and told them that they did not have the
right business license that they needed
a secondhand business license and they
said that they would be shut down if
they didn't get the right business
license within seven days merchants Mike
Moffat and business advocates like
Barton aren't taking it lying down they
pulled together and they're pushing back
it's never easy to fight city hall but
they're giving it their best shot and
after all they have nothing to lose but
their livelihoods it'll take a rewrite
of the other regulations we could do
that first by emergency legislation and
then you know hopefully by permanent
legislation so I mean it's going to take
some time but we've started the process
and we've got DC I raise attention so
we're hopeful it's it just seems like
just so heavy-handed that can easily
just just destroy businesses like what
we're pulling for you well thank you
good luck thanks
you